et pour en débattre
gama d'adina cofondateur du mouvement
des droits civiques bonsoir gamin nabina
merci d'être avec nous ses côtés nader
allouche journalistes bonsoir à vous
également donc une polémique avec cette
jeune femme qui a placé mais entre
guillemets volontairement je le dis
alors qu'il n'était pas un blasphème
pour la justice vous comprenez déjà que
cette affaire est créé la polémique m
alabina ça vous a étonné je serai tenu
pour tout vous dire ce quiz sur cette
information à deux jours s'est monté en
épingle dans les réseaux sociaux je
m'attendais pas à une telle ampleur
parce que bompard kaenzig amie de 16 ans
et quand j'ai vu quand j'ai vu à quel à
quel niveau on est arrivé de débat
national sur une affaire qui est au
départ privé chaud ça extraordinaire
qu'est ce que ça dit justement
selon vous que ça y est atteint ce
niveau de débat c'est que ça te dit
quelque chose lui clairement la france
est scindé en deux aujourd'hui il ya les
laïcs et les laïcards qui sont alors d
day et puis il ya les autres qui sont
croyants pas nécessairement musulmans
vous avez juste qu'ils sont là dedans
qui ont j'ai l'occasion de disputer avec
avec quelqu'un du consistoire ces
questions là les intéresse vraiment
parce qu'ils sont inquiets je le cache
pas et puis les catholiques évidemment
et évidemment les musulmans qui sont en
première ligne parce que c'est ce qui
pose problème en france aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que là on peut se poser la
question de savoir pourquoi on est
scindé en deux nevers hallouj
écoutez moi je crois que l affaire est
grave
nous parlons d'une jeune fille de 16 ans
qui se trouve aujourd'hui menacée
empêcher d'aller à l'école dans le pays
des droits de l'homme parce qu'elle a
dit ça me toute cette phrase tout à fait
anodine je crois l'islam c'est de la
merde
écoutez thème est une religion de haine
le coran c'est de la merde pardonnez-moi
d'auros cette phrase mais voilà c'est ce
qu'elle a dit précisément
j'aimerais que nos concitoyens musulmans
nous prouve le contraire
la vérité c'est que vous attaquer fort
la voudra voir quelqu un comble
madame ce que l'islam est la religion
d'un prophète qui dixit les sources
scripturaires de l'islam lui même était
un pédophile où il ya eu des relais
l'islam est là venant jouer et prendre
le relais de la jeune fille la fille
anne l'islam est la religion d'un
prophète qui a eu des relations
sexuelles avec une fillette de 9 ans
aicha cela se trouve dans la biographie
canonique de mohammad et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle en
irak madame il y a eu un projet de loi
pour abaisser l'âge légal du mariage à 9
ans pour les filles et aujourd'hui nous
avons des organisations musulmanes en
france tels que ben youssef qui invite
des hommes comme monsieur al qardaoui
qui nous disent pas moins que cela il
est légal d'avoir des relations
sexuelles avec des fillette de 9 ans
alors moi je demande à nos concitoyens
musulmans qu'il nous prouve que l'islam
est une religion de valeur pour ça
encore faudrait-il qu'il encore
faudrait-il qu'ils réforment leurs
discours et peut-être aussi qu'ils
réforment leur historiographie bon
nadera louche je vais je vais laisser
rêvons de gamme à la vina vous
vous avez conscience effectivement ce
genre de propos peuvent extrêmement
choqués notamment les musulmans qui nous
regardent ça peut être potentiellement
assez explosif vous assumez vous vous
êtes dans une forme de provocation si
ces propos les chocs
alors il n'y a qu'une chose à faire
qu'ils quittent l'islam où l'orthodoxie
musulmane plaide pour des mouvements
réels des terreaux de l'allée des
musulmans tout à fait modéré qui sont
catastrophés par mais important
interrogent leurs textes
ce n'est pas moi qui dis que ma maman
yamada a eu des relations sexuelles avec
une jeune fille de 9 ans c'est écrit
dans sa biographie canonique alors que
les écoulements gamme alors lorsqu'un
aîné je venais je reconnais que je veux
mais je lui dis la chose qui nous dit
que ça fait l'extrême droite la chute et
du propos parce que c'est les gens
d'extrême droite qui à longueur de
journée d'un réseaux sociaux nous
balance neuf ans neuf ans neuf ans
d'abord il a jamais heureuse aux
relations sexuelles avec une femme de 9
ans je rappelle que celles décédées
c'est un avis voilà maintenant c'est pas
le coran radeef autant petit jeu tandis
qu on en dise qu'ouvrir depuis
l'interdication islamique
il y a donc le coran qui le texte on
avait les odieux et tout ça et il y à ce
qu'on appelle et a dit donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle la tradition la suite de
la sounna lacenas attrition la vie c'est
l'état qui disent comment se comporter
le prophète alors joué pour les juifs
qu'on a fait le tennis on les nourrit la
population du texte c'est ça je vais te
finir parce que je tenais quand même un
peu mais ma religion que monsieur donc
la réunion appelle ça un monsieur que je
suis chercheur justement sur les vrais
musulmans d'angers
on vient d'une famille musulmane j'ai
travaillé j'ai trahi la mosquée de paris
dommage donc plus haut c'est donc moi je
m'intéresse aux textes je m'intéresse
pas la propagande d'extrême droite
hu est très claire les a dit qu'il dit
être authentique il ya toute une série
de maladies ces textes qui décrivent la
vie du prophète
oui c'est pas le texte du 1 et du magnat
2 c'est pas tout seul ce sens oui mais
monsieur vous unir à ce ne sont pas ce
ne sont pas des années ce projet pas je
vous corrige s'écouter parler voilà que
sanitaire à 10 en arabe charme monsieur
pas donnez nous la traduction n'a jamais
les circonstances de ce départ est
question va être écouté parler donc je
finis ce que je dis ces femmes a dit ce
dont ils parlent qu'ils sont une
description de ce qui s'est passé du
temps du prophète ont été reportés deux
cents ans plus tard l'authenticité de
pas mal d'entre eux peut être remis en
question parce que c'est pas des textes
révélés
c'est pas des textes qui ont été
reconstitués tout de suite il a fait 200
ans
bora les moustiques et les deux
personnes qui ont fait des recherches
pendant trente ans donc après on n'a ni
on évite tout donné à 10 mais par contre
c'est ce propos qui est tenue où on
parle de pédophilie mais c'est grave
alors quand on fait un blessé grave en
effet que des gens pas finir j'ai pu
parler tranquillement avec vous c'est
pas possible ça va quand même mais leur
peine de m'écouter
écoutez donc j'ai fini mon propos un
historien et pas des rigolos un
historien sérieux vous expliquerai ce
qui s'est passé pourquoi le prophète
s'est marié avec au 9 11 femmes
c'était une question de stratégie
d'alliance avec des tribus donc c'est
uniquement pour ça la femme qui la
chérie elle avait 40 ans je le rappelle
disant puisque lui alors quand vous me
sortez ce genre de d2 délire pour
essayer de salir une religion sur
samantha maintenant dos revient ce sujet
une fille de 16 ans fille de 16 ans
dérape
alors les insultes que vous avez
produite malheureusement sont
incomplètes j'ai tout entendu
très loin si c'était juste ça bon c'est
pas bien mais c'est elle va beaucoup
plus loin elle va dire elle ne dit pas
je critique en région comme ce cas les
16 de leur rattrapage un peu minable qui
a laissé derrière elle attaque des
musulmans alors fort contextualiser elle
prend
son premier propose c'est de dire quoi
moi il a raflé pas moins mais c'est pas
ma tasse de thé ok très bien donc à une
connotation ethnique j'ai pas aimé
ensuite tu étais un sujet répond de
travers on n'a pas le détail et après
qu'est ce qui se passe
juste derrière commencé à insulter quoi
pas les religions l'islam alors gamelle
la binah pour pour explication alors
déjà il ya une décision du sni ça il
faut bien le dire à plus de monde voilà
c'était pas effectivement la prison
tanguay rendue rapidement
vous accusez la justice nous sommes dans
france vous accusez la justice française
de rendre des décisions arbitraires
j'étais émerveillé wenger de dire si
demain avec un sous-entendu non je suis
à côté de hugh j'ai entendu monsieur
d'entendre accusez-vous la justice
française d'avoir pris cette décision
trop rapidement est-ce que vous accusez
la justice française d'avoir condamné
dreyfus enfin arrêter de dire ça mais
pas la perfection et 2 6 3 il ya aussi
des pressions du gouvernement et aussi
une pression sociale
il ya tout un chacun il ya une
expression d'une guerre de 25 ans il a
gardé selon elle a gardé des douanes
dans le sens et fait justement on lui a
reproché de sa ne vont pas respecter
l'indépendance de la justice est plutôt
d'aller dans le sens effectivement la
gamme bio est dans son rôle elle est
juste elle dit elle est garante des
institutions et sur l'indépendance de la
justice
se prononce sur une chose parce qu'elle
est à la jetro si choqué si on parle
quand même pas de show gentil tout est
dit c'est assez violente à l'examen de
la part d'une gamine on aimerait qu'elle
avons la justice a abandonné contre elle
c'est pour elle une caution personnelle
une opinion personnelle qui on le
rappelle n'est pas condamnée en france
les appels à la haine à la incitations à
la haine qui sont condamnés cette jeune
femme pourvus ce pour notre information
expliqué avoir tenu ces propos avoir été
après avoir été insulté harcelés par des
internautes voilà alors on va pas se
substituer à la justice ici
effectivement mais est ce que ça veut
dire tout simplement de payer un peu
plus critique et toutes les religions et
que c'est totalement explosif ce sont
des sujets qui sont envoyées c'est vrai
que voilà c'est un petit peu dur alors
mesdames sur france inter sur france
inter radio du service public français
nous avons entendu cette chanson tout à
fait inomineo jésus et [ __ ] oui quelle a
été la réaction de la conférence des
évêques de france jeu at on eu une
réaction aujourd'hui de pouvoir at on eu
une réaction égale à celle du délégué
général du cfcm qui a osé dire sur un
plateau de radio elle l'a bien cherché
elle doit assumer les conséquences de ce
qu'elle a dit il ya un homme seul visage
lorsque lorsque le père jacques hamel a
été assassiné par un terroriste ce qui
leur a valu tant de l'islam quelle a été
la réaction de la conférence des évêques
de france et en particulier de
l'archevêque de paris c'était une
réalité dont il tombe un jour en dignité
et en mesurer cava move aimerions avoir
en france des musulmans comme nos
catholique
c'est à dire des musulmans monsieur mais
soumis non non seulement des catholiques
sont soumis aujourd'hui restera un jour
dit donc sur le plateau de ruches la
médaille que la référence jeu avec deux
français
ils ont soumis à l'insulté le
catholicisme français jamais seul os et
les goûts
et vous insultez la journée une blague
on va donc en est la laïcité assouma
lorette l'église catholique donc pour
vous la laisse ma pouvoir pour maman
l'histoire la soirée est une mesure de
soumission de l'église catholique
histoire mais vous connaissez pas
l'histoire yorosso vision erronée car un
gamin la vie n'a qu'à préciser votre
pensée au récent le calme et on est vidé
je suis un cas mais j'ai du mal à
soutenir l'idée c'est de calmer parce
qu'il disait beaucoup de bêtise et
l'ignorance g
quand on est ignorant d'histoire on
parle pas comme ça donc je commence pas
vu effectivement 1905 par une voix ils
ont je parle de la gauche écarté
l'église de l'éducation ils ont écarté
du pouvoir ils ont écarté de tous les
moyens de pression quel état avez ils
ont libéré l'état de l'église c'est une
réalité ça vous plaît pas c'est comme ça
la laïcité s'est fondée non pas pour
apaiser les tensions n'avaient plus en
france elle s'est fondée uniquement pour
écarter des 10 de l'état c'est tout ça
vous plaît pas reprenez bouquin vous
allez adorer ensuite deuxième chose
concernant vos écarts vous allez parler
des terroristes jour par rapport à ce
sujet je veux dire c'est pas parce que
de trois excités tard et qui ont été
ratés dans la vie et qui ont pris
décalage on se revendiquant d'un du nez
bulleuses qui connaissent même pas qu'il
faut confondre ça avec avec le reste
j'ai parlé d'une histoire qui vous
intéressait hélas à vous intéresser
on a fait monter en épingle une fille de
16 ans qui est insultante une erreur
pour cour d'assises ce serait parce
qu'ils étaient dix c'est beaucoup plus
grave
ok ça ça mérite la une ça mérite pas la
lune il ya une fille qui a été violée il
ya un mois par deux voyous d'origine
maghrébine elle a été filmée sur ce chat
ça aurait dû faire le tour des médias
parce que les médias les réseaux sociaux
font monter en épingle des choses sales
sales on n'a pas parlé pourquoi on n'a
pas parlé pourtant été violée ce terral
et un garçon qui a été tué par deux
voyous en banlieue il a été jeté dans le
canal de l'ourcq et ça a été filmé sur
cette chatte ça fait marrer tout toutes
les racailles sauf ce malgré sa famille
pourquoi on n'en parle pas de ça là il
ya mort d'homme il ya une femme qui a
été violée peau causée par là dessus
alors par les jeunes filles à
déconnecter les icaunais qui a provoqué
parce qu'on l'a provoquée ok on
l'approché pourquoi parce que madame
j'ai appelé aujourd'hui 1 qu'elle était
homosexuelle normaux d'ikea le droit
chère madame combien de viols y at il en
france car tous les jours du mondial et
à lille en france où les jours et y
compris
filmé et diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux
la différence entre cette affaire qui
est un faits divers et la ferme il à ce
que la paire milla et politique
elle touche elle touche à la liberté de
blasphémer la ferme il a une dimension
politique vous le savez très bien je
vais pas vous vous le savez c'est que
j'ai mélangé en récupérer qualité la
dimension politique d'un violent filmées
et diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux il
y à lui que le vent eut il revient il y
a eu plusieurs lois justement de la
série entre les violences sexuelles et
je voudrais pas sauvage dans quel
contexte cette jeune femme est allaité
violet est filmé appelé moins cher
monsieur dans le cadre est comme
végétales apotex léger moins formel dit
non je ne sais pas c'est vous qui avez
lancé ce sujet je leur explique enel a
été violée dans le contexte de
l'obsession d'exister sur internet et
sur la société c'est violent de voyous
qui est d'ouvrir deux voyous mais qui
qui je vois lui j'ai pas langue ou leur
prénom c'est comme un jeu de fish
monsieur bouchard les bonnes affaires
moi je les ai mis la chanson chère
madame c'est à dire que vous avez
aujourd'hui en banlieue dans ce temps
dans le doubs de nombreux territoires
français à majorité musulmane aux pays
qui subissent des violences sexuelles
également des mutilations sexuelles
je vous rappelle qu'à londres il y
encore quelques mois il y avait un
procès pour excision et que lundi quand
les cher monsieur
les violets la sorte mais là c'est que
j'ai lus par edgar sexuelle est ce vous
dit qu'on n'avait pas de violence
sexuelle en france sont commises dans un
contexte musulmans c'est louise et
raciste menée par ac tion je viens
demander des frais généraux étaient
fantaisistes
la plupart des femmes qui sont tués en
france on a la liste dommage l'existence
bizarrement c'est le nom d'européennes
ça veut dire que majoritairement pas
tout
il ya 10% d'étrangères et des
européennes les mecs violents dans le
monde entier ont des comportements
violents vis-à-vis des femmes et c'est
les sagouins c'est compliqué ce que joe
g et non pas bien sûr battra dans les
bonnes nouvelles d'une femme battue
vous êtes une femme bourgeoisie
française c'est koné et niang a battu à
saint denis
quels sont vos moyens quels sont vos
amis à tout le monde mais la police est
grave et qu'il a été la police et
c'était assez compliqué justement il y
avait peu des coudes sur ces questions
de violence conjugale est effectivement
le cas n'avait pas l'air pour le coup
particulier en scène on sait que
monsieur nous dit jean la liste nous dit
dans les quartiers musulmans parce qu'il
ya des quartiers musulmans c'est
l'arrivée ce nouveau défaut à un
quartier à majorité musulmane il ya qu'à
venir les gens qui malgré deux lignes
sont pas tous musulmans dans ces
quartiers là il y aurait soi-disant une
sorte de syndrome ça me rappelle au cas
belles choses ce truc que je me ferai
avait beaucoup de chrétiens d'algérie ou
du maroc de tunisie aujourd'hui dans les
quartiers à part des musulmans gelé les
genres rdc sont musulmans dont les
congolais sont musulmans non mais c'est
un truc de fou
la vérité c'est qu'il ya très peu de
personnes d'origine maghrébine qui ont
une religion différente mais un passage
dans les regards à l'égard d'un mois le
rival dans les quartiers dans les cités
populaires c'est comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent il ya des concentrations
d'étrangers les portugais sont musulmans
mais jamais espagne 2 sont musulmans ils
sont au moins vous avez vous aidé osé
dire dans les quartiers à majorité
musulmane celles auxquelles plus de viol
ça s'appelle du racisme
non j'ai dit cher monsieur que
aujourd'hui dire quand il ya une réalité
il ya une actualité sa violence sexuelle
est en relation avec l'histoire d'un
mensonge non mais bon dans son élément
dans des bas de toute façon vous les
papas des coréens à patxi compliqué
gamin laïquement est effectivement
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il est plus
compliqué peut-être c'est l'accusation
entre cadre de votre contradicteur à
côté est-ce qu'il est plus compliqué de
se les poser cette question à l'époque
de charlie hebdo de critiquer l'islam
enfoncé sont pas contenus en ligne et
mahomet ce qu'on peut critiquer il est
attaqué c'est une chose mais il ya une
différence entre critiquer et insulter
à l'époque nous a fait le coup de je
suis charlie battant sèchement millas
encore plus ridicule saison bref un peu
ridicule je suis chardy de charme se
voudrait pas fini j'avoue venait
dix véhicules cela s'appelle un
comparatif de supériorité ça veut dire
charlie hebdo je suis jamais été
ridicules jouer aussi il est encore plus
ridicule que je suis à l'extrême grand
monsieur ces stands alors je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire ça mais il y a eu
besoin d'un riche de beaucoup de
chansons lui est mort né en mai relève
de la rédaction de charlie et d'allemand
et c'est le drame il a juste pour finir
rapidement donc jean professionnellement
les freins avant d'être kucova jeudi à
l'époque on nous a intimé d'être charlie
et aujourd'hui je suis mis lac kir et
dit que sais je suis mis la quina on
vous a intimé on vous a obligé d'en
passer mais est synonyme d'obliger les
débuts de france à connaître assez bien
la langue même d'obliger pour me battre
je finis on a que je veux dire par une
seule gamme el abine a bien retenu sur
nyon tout ce que je me kiffe
je veux dire simplement c'est que par
rapport à charlie on nous a dit vous
êtes vous vous êtes avec eux ou vous
êtes contre syde et or c'est pas comme
ça que prédisent les cheveux on doit
réfléchir aux izards ya de quoi moi je
suis canard enchaîné rappelle le père
jacques deray cabut
dommage il était tué donc j'adorerais
cabu mais j'adorais cabu dans le canal
dommages dans assez juste pourquoi c'est
ridicule ouvert éléments les mots
d'ordre est révélateur de rage de
l'importance dommage pour vous j'adorais
cabu dommage pour vous je traduis
faisait du bruit avec le français donc
j'ai pour dom samara en plus que notre
assistant ah ben non ils vont pas
raciste raciste n'importe quoi même
origine que moi ça fait rigoler bref on
6 passes et que à l'époque
qu'avez vous êtes pour ou contre charlie
moi j'ai dit que j'aimais pas charlie
hebdo pourquoi pas parce que tu es des
dessinateurs je suis déçu et en bande
dessinée
dommage donc quid des dessinateurs c'est
inique c'est intolérable
en revanche moi ma préférence est
exportée sur le canard enchaîné parce
que je rigolais que le canard enchaîné
charlie dont ne faisait pas rire merci
comme bourvil et louis de funès on n'a
pas le même humour c'est une question
d'humour là ça devient quoi si vous
n'êtes pas charles et vous verrez qu
minel un terroriste mais c'est quoi ce
délire
moi j'ai aucun rapport avec ces gens là
les rackets dont bon louxor décalage
pour tuer les gens je déteste ce sont
des musulmans orthodoxes
absolument
qui pratique le ritz appui pratique âmes
des catégories de sunnites qui
pratiquent manning et 4x unite à la
lettre à la lettre comme on le
pratiquait au maroc d'ailleurs à la
lettre b face au maroc absolument vous
êtes ignorant le maroc et ce avant le
sillon du maroc que ça te disais
ignorant que passe-t-il pour les
musulmans qui quittent l'islam au maroc
l'apostasié la poule apostasie avec un
peu de monnaie à la peine de mort c'est
dans le droit marocain géant messieurs
peut-être que le maroc ne l'a pas
pratiqué fallu l'inventer train
peut-être peut-être qu'il ne l'a pas
pratiqué mais aussi le port du pantalon
chez les femmes en france est interdit
par le code napoléon est ce qu'on
applique non ces véhicules donc pour
revenir à ce quizz et quand monsieur ne
connais pas la banlieue il la connaît
pas du tout quand monsieur caricature
abonnés pour être ici c est dire si moi
j'étais moins musulmans c'est qu'il ait
jamais été et comme je n'avais jamais
l'idée je vis à paris je vais leur
parler ses lauriers à paris et je me
déplace régulièrement en banlieue
parisienne à neuilly c'est pas la
banlieue mais si seulement j'avais le
fallait au verdier cher monsieur je vais
tous les grands alliés je vais tous les
lundis étudié à aubervilliers à la
maison des sciences de l'homme cher
monsieur donc vous voyez à cbc maltais
la mairie vire de match pour une vidéo
de la daurade encore mais plus
sérieusement quand quelqu'un nous réduit
une question de violence féminine et ça
c'est gravissime
en disant ce n'est pas réduit j'ai eu
les résultats étaient aujourd'hui ses
dirigeants vous êtes ridicules mais on
va on va aujourd'hui il y a
aujourd'hui hier aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
ils paient pas ils haine de violence de
violence à l'encontre des femmes en
masculine et de violences sexuelles à
l'encontre des femmes en relation avec
kristen et quand on parle de violence
sexuelle ça n'est pas que le voile ce
sont aussi les mutilations sexuelles je
vous rappelle le travail extraordinaire
de linda gail curiel qui est secrétaire
général de la ligue du droit
international des femmes par simone de
beauvoir le kia pratiqués dans les cris
qui a fait interdire l'excision en
france l'excision est parti et dans les
vallées calibre à regarder
aujourd'hui vous avez des mesures qui
ont été mises en place justement pour
pouvoir identifier les jeunes filles qui
sont menacés de l'excision ou qui ont
déjà subi déjà scoré d'excision il est
socialement bien des jeunes filles
souvent nous a conviés de fille madame
je vous invite à aller sur le site de la
ligue du droit international des femmes
il ya un rapport tout à fait détaillé
sur le sujet aujourd'hui a même des
discussions franco allemandes des
discussions franco-allemandes très
sérieuse dans le vent latéral des
bateaux sur le problème de l'excision et
des violences mallorytown celle ci parce
que monsieur et ignorants de la chose
excisions pratiquées par les pays
subsahariens c'est pas une tradition
musulmane contrairement aux mensonges qu
elle préférait les gîtes la pratique un
peu malheureusement elle est condamnée
par les musulmans et toutes les écoles
de condamne parce que ça n'a rien à voir
avec la circoncision l'excision est une
mutilation qui est condamnable
malheureusement et qui dans les
traditions quittait préexistait l'islam
ça monsieur vous dira pas plus qu'il ne
sait pas donc entier par l'excision me
fait rigoler vision n'était à pratiquer
par les chrétiens au soudan ni par les
arabes
elle n'est pas pratiqué par l'église en
les armant mes lettres elle est
pratiquée par un musulman elle est pas
réellement ragon pied pendant et en
egypte les coptes ne pratiquent pas les
fusions les corses ne pourra pas revenir
soit famille là bas je le dis
franchement je condamne le fait qu'on
les fait monter en épingle une affaire
kurdes eurent essais privés
je condamne à fait leurs adieux
justement ne pas intervenir fermée celle
rouge et jaune ter poliment la garde des
sceaux a donné ce rôle a dit mais ça
pulse
malheureusement ce qui est beaucoup de
maladresse dans dossier mais en réalité
moi ce que je note c'est qu'est-ce que
j'étais ce matin la radio c'est que
cette jeune fille saison donc à 16 ans
on n'est pas fort mais politiquement
elle a fait un coup de réactions si une
réaction épidermique y en a eu et je la
comprends parce qu'on la suite est
semble-t-il son homosexualité après sa
réaction était extrêmement
disproportionnée vis-à-vis des crétins
qui ont attaqué de l'autre côté
l'éthique et la masse des versions des
crétins et a pas de discuter accepter
que quelqu'un qui est paroles grossières
l'or continue pour trouver
selon mme hadad il a elle a eu une
parole grossia à l'encontre de qui est
ce que le commencement il aurait pu à
leur tour en est ce que le coin est une
personnalité juridique est ce que vous
connaissez à l'avant
montré en particules est-ce que ça qu'on
est avec eux sur les joueurs sont alités
juridique à la non total en france il
est interdit d'attaquer des personnes
réellement l'année passée c'est la
belgique hier monsieur leur aide a été
classé les premiers demandent pas c'est
que c'est pas le problème de savoir ce
qui est ou pas ce qu'ils ont sous coup
la loi c-32 sens ça blesse ou pas moi
j'allais dire quand quelqu'un insulte
jésus dommage mais sa famille la coupe
et c'est génial africains ainsi que j'ai
utilisées et à chaque fois il s'énerve
non car quelqu'un suit jésus je trouve
que c'est intolérable il s'agit donc on
affûte hitler trouve ça intolérable
aussi charlebois la non non non non non
non je connais ce canton en canton un
phénomène trouve ça inacceptable
également en quoi mao mais tu es plus
sacré que n'importe quel autre homme sur
cette planète parce qu'il ya un milliard
d'individus à me croire mais personne
évidemment c'est pas plus sacrée à ce
qu'il ya pour les bouddhistes le bouddha
est sacré pour les chrétiens jésus est
sacré pour les charmes de briser sacré
célébrer mais j'ai entendu nous vivons
dans une république laïque
nous n'avons pas à rothonay nous n'avons
pas à reconnaître la seconde mettra la
qualité des microbilles la république
respecte les cultes et les gens vous ne
respectez pas mon char mairie on termine
la gamme alabina berra douche pour ce
débat plus qu'animé merci à vous tous